so welcome ladies and gentlemen I am a
professor here at the GSB for the last
five years I've been teaching a course
on sales sales force management I just
did a double session yesterday as a
matter of fact and so I'm on the verge
of losing my voice my strategy today is
to let you and the panelists do as much
of your talking as possible I just want
to set this up for you first of all I'm
going to let the panelists introduce
themselves I trust that you have your
BIOS but I'm gonna pose a question for
them that will allow them to tell you
something about who they are and how
they fit into this topic again the
reason that I'm here is not because I'm
a marketing professor but because I've
been teaching sales for a little while
and in part of our course one of the
things that we focus on are the
challenges associated with early stage
sales so that's where we want to focus
here now let me try and set this up a
little bit because it occurs to me that
when you look at this collection of
panelists gasps the question well if
they kind of are coming to early stage
sales what's the most important part of
what they did
starting out did they come at it from
more of a marketing perspective or did
they come at it for more of a sales
force and sales management perspective
so I'm gonna let them tell you a little
bit about that what it does is it sets
up two possible topics of discussion if
you're more interested in marketing than
the big early sales challenge is how do
you build a reputation and a brand with
no budget for doing it and so we'll talk
about so it's possible we could talk
about some of the early stage branding
challenges for companies that are trying
to get sales on the other hand if what
you do is a lot of business-to-business
you sell a large technical complex
product then part of your challenge may
be well how do I
an organization with selling capability
where do I find it how do I build it how
do I get it off the ground there's other
many questions that relate to that as
well
well I proposed to do is ask a question
to the panelists that will let them sort
of tell you what their perspective is
and then most of the time we'll be
letting you ask questions that takes
your interest and matches it with these
guys expertise so we can have an
interesting Q&A so I'll start with a few
questions we may spend the first half an
hour or so with me posing some questions
to bring out these issues and I'm gonna
turn it over to you and is moderator all
I'll do is try to identify as many
people as I can and get your questions
okay so let me start then with the first
question for our panel I'd like to ask
you guys each individually kind of
introduce yourself some of you've been
involved with more than one organization
so you may want to do a little bit of
choosing picking and choosing here but
at the early stage when your
organization launched when you were
trying to get it off the ground what was
more important marketing or sales we
start with that can we start with Brad
all right sure so um I'm brad stroh I
co-founded class of 2002 when I
co-founded with a classmate of mine from
o2 a company called freedom Financial
Network which includes a bunch of
direct-to-consumer financial services
products and Bill's comm which is a lead
generation in consumer finance portal
that sells leads we're about a 400
person company now and our sales
organizations probably 170 of those
people in sales is very very core to
what we do we are probably more of a
marketing driven sales organization so
we try to turn our sales group into
efficient systems and processes and with
direct consumer marketing ideally turn
them into kind of order takers not you
know perfect but so I'd say early on we
spent more time money and effort on
marketing and establishing a brand and
generating leads and less time on sales
organization we've got a lot of
failures through that process by the way
and determining Commission's culture
several turnovers of VPS of sales as an
aside it says sales organization in our
company and probably in a lot of
organizations is the most difficult
group to manage for cultural comp tons
of reasons but it's early on we probably
on marketing than know about self my
name is Andy Lots class of 97 here the
GSB and just did one thing packed my
truck up right after graduation drove
down to San Diego and started a watch
company in 1997 you know the old economy
companies are really kicking ass you
know new economy stuff was happening so
I was a lucky guy
it was thinking about starting in
business and my partner came to me and
said hey buddy what do you think of
watches and so had time to noodle on it
here at school and there's 400 brands of
watches it's been around for 500 years
you know why in the world would you want
another world and I was thinking about
what we had just at the get-go we
understood a distribution channel we we
knew the sales guys we knew the reps we
need the distri knew the distributors
and at that point it was really more of
a marketing job to convince these guys
we already knew that there was a value
to carrying our brand so I would
probably answer the question we started
marketing to our sales guys why why in
the world would you want to be our sale
guy and from that point we tapped in the
distribution senator distribution
network that we already were familiar
with which was specialty Sporting Goods
around the world snow surf and
skateboard word about 30 countries
probably like have about 120 sales reps
around around the world and sell to the
youth market retailers
hi I'm Elizabeth Verducci I'm with
Medallia and we're an enterprise
feedback management company and I head
up their hospitality practice I've been
with them since we were founded and we
basically targeted the hospitality
industry is our initial industry because
we felt that there was a great
opportunity there and so my role was
really not only to kind of help with you
know development of the product but also
out there selling and we kind of it's
kind of interesting is we're
business-to-business you know type of
organization and so I think that you
know the story might be slightly
different here
we definitely focused on strategic
marketing from a product design pricing
target market perspective in terms of
really understanding that and putting
together a product that we felt was
really far above and beyond what the
competitive offerings were out there but
we completely focused on sales at the
beginning I mean I think you know we
probably are still working on our
branding really and a lot of it was you
know kind of the day-to-day people who
were the business people doing a lot of
the selling and we just recently
actually hired a sales organization last
year so we've been in business since you
know eight for eight years now
and the I graduated in 93 so I'm feeling
a little old next all these young guns
here and the the founders of the company
we're GSP 95 everyone Omar Saul co Class
of 93
we're not the oldest together so you
know my perspective on this comes from
founding two companies co-founding two
companies with another guy couldn't be
here Matt Glickman one was BabyCenter
which was a consumer-facing web business
that we started in 96 and it had two
businesses blended in one there was an
advertising business would had a very
traditional media sales model and I did
all the initial selling and ran that
sales organization so I'll talk about
that throughout the session but it also
had a consumer e-commerce business which
was very marketing lead and so it was
very in vogue to try to blend business
types and it still is to some extent in
the consumer sector on the Internet and
then in 2001 we started Merced Systems
which is a classic enterprise software
company and that's the business that we
continued to run today were and that's
entirely sales
and I did all the initial selling and
run the sales organization we now have
you know infrastructure of VP of Sales
and about 25 people selling in the
average order for us is over a million
dollars so it's a very considered long
sale cycle
structure and as a result I'd say you
know heavily heavily sales led and not
marketing lead and all that I'll comment
more as the day goes on but it's
pleasure to be with everyone excited to
be on the panel all right thank you all
and for the introduction I think I can
follow this up with a question but you'd
be able to answer whether or not your
focus was principally marketing or
principally sales that is you know at
the very early stages before your
company has really solidified its
reputation how did it get those first
few sales what were the strategies you
used to kind of get it off the ground
certainly um you're gonna find that
there's this these guys start asking
their questions you get to sit next to
well I did it I mean we bootstrapped our
company my co-founder and I think lack
of capital for us is sort of
necessitated that we did everything um
reality is that turned out to be pretty
beneficial going forward as we learned
what resonated with consumers directly
what how the sales cycle worked our
challenge was handing it over to a team
but how do we get our initial sales then
we did a couple things without a brand
which was we outworked people you know
matter-of-factly as an entrepreneur you
sort of have to the other is we
partnered with some channel partners
where we could kind of dovetail under
their brands so in consumer finance
there's a whole bunch of companies that
have big brands and we partnered with
some of the biggest in trying to create
products directly for them to service
their consumers and when you get a
referral from a loyal customer of
another organization and consumer
finance you try to turn it into
order-taking so for us it was kind of
partnering with channel partners to get
those leads a little bit
yeah mostly hand-waving that we we could
deliver a product that we had yet to
deliver the very first sale I still
remember God gave me an order form and I
looked around and our tradeshow booth
and said we're gonna put this yeah I'm
more of a chronic background and my
partner was a marketing background so
the sales thing kind of hit us in the
face but uh like I said before we work
in a very traditional consumer product
channel so we solicited and and
recruited sales reps and that was that
was really the first sale why would
these guys want to work with us and then
I'm like unlike mark our average order
was probably about $1,500 so we had to
have a lot of them and that meant more
sales reps so we recruited recruited
about 15 sales reps and then tried to
give those guys every single tool they
asked for which was it sounds a lot
easier than it actually was
you know hooking up our product cycle
with their sales cycle and and getting
them sales tools and Commission
structures and warranties and credit
credit people everything that they
needed once that was up they felt
comfortable putting their reputation on
the line and placing the product and I
think there was a lot of time finger
crossing because they were using their
establishment relationship to it there
with the buyers almost to do a favor for
us they place the product it looks cool
it will sell based really just on their
own good and so the proximal through and
then that was easier from now so before
we go into Elizabeth let me ask you Andy
what did you say to convince them I mean
convinced me the reps you know yeah yeah
hire that rep say what are you gonna do
why should I come and try and sell
watches for you well I guess one of the
things we were going for us was very
practical things there you didn't have
to get a bigger van you didn't have to
get a bigger warehouse you already had
relationships this was just sort of an
add-on sale to their existing brands
good so hey Jim you're talking to the
guys over at villains about your
clothing line
this is complementary to that you know
it's something new in the marketplace it
has something it adds a little bit of
more flavor to your sales pitch on the
other other things and and you know what
basically I tried to get him say you
know it's 10% your time but it could be
20% of revenue to the sales reps okay
and try to make our program as easy as
possible for the reps that gets my
attention when you start talking about
money are the margins and commissions
and so on good did you have to be extra
aggressive there no we we were pretty
standard on commission rates in our
category you know accessories and action
sports is anywhere from from eight to
twelve percent so we stuck at nine and
but no commissions I mean how we get
paid when people wanted to get paid when
they place the order instead of getting
paid when we got paid and that was a
little bit battle so we want to recruit
our sales guys's as as credit people as
well okay they they want a nice clean
little you know boa rounded package to
say I've already got the relationships
this is gonna take very little time and
and I could do it okay
well tell you what I'll think about it
Elizabeth how about you sure I think
this is a really great question because
it's a really hard thing to do I mean I
remember sitting across the table from
someone we were first out selling we
hadn't even have one client at time and
this person told me it would be a career
limiting move for me to hire you
yeah say you come back from that meeting
you think okay what are we gonna do now
and I think you know we're in the same
sort of situation that mark is because
we're an enterprise software company our
sales are in the hundreds of thousands
to millions of dollars and you know you
have no clients and how do you convince
somebody by and I think there are a
couple of things I would say one of them
is you rely on other reputations like
your personal reputation your networks I
mean our first major client came out of
a connection we made throughout a budget
of long ago GSB grad who you know
basically was willing to give us the
time of day and listen to us because of
that connection you didn't know anything
other than that and he was at a very
senior level and one of our target
companies and we you know having the
business people go out and sell was
hugely helpful because you have a
certain amount of credibility based on
the reputation
you had from your prior experience so I
think the fact that I came out of the
hospital in straight I was a pretty
senior level and uh you know one of the
large hospitality companies I could talk
their language that helped a lot and a
certain amount of kind of really
understanding you know what I mean it
sounds so basic but really understanding
what like your customers pain points are
what me you really feel for them and
really appealing to that because you
know this is like great company levar
but we had it was we were actually out
there we had just finished meet spent a
lot of time developing the product we
really tried to put product together
that we thought it was going to appeal
to these people and um we spent probably
at six to nine months of our initial
startup time just doing that and we
first went out selling in the summer of
2001 and this is the hospitality chef
course and I was in Memphis and I'm in a
meeting on September 10th 2001 we had we
didn't have any customers got on a plane
headed home in the next morning my
opinion is what happened right and we
were just absolutely convinced that with
the end of the company because we
thought you know who's gonna go out and
spend a million dollars right with
what's going on and the interesting
thing was that we actually had a product
that was right at that point in time
there were a lot of companies that
suspended this is basically its customer
feedback products right surveying there
were a lot of customers that had clients
that had suspended their programs at
that one time today Jim thought it was a
couple million dollars that they could
save to the bottom line at that stage
get knowing what's gonna be happening
and luckily you know at the time
everybody is doing very traditional
surveying the a mail or phone and these
were very expensive programs even though
our program you know still a lot of
money it's a huge cost savings for them
and so I think at the end of the day we
were able to you know find that that one
thing that really hooked those this
initial customers and once we got those
first customers that now we got Hilton
as a client and you know that name
carried us through a lot of other
meetings but I what I'd say is that
sales in the early days is intensely
personal yours
you're forming a relationship with a
person who you hope will become your
champion and as a result that you know
their their personal individual
interests overlap with what their
company needs but there are other things
that they're looking for individually
and you have to connect with them and
figure out what they're looking for and
in the two
they come to mind for me one was I'll
never forget John Burbank pampers brand
manager Procter and Gamble is the first
customer we had at BabyCenter and
Dominic cipolla head of a call center
for unit of GE which was a first
customer for a firmer set and you know
each of them individually wanted some
innovation part of their personal
portfolio they wanted to do something in
that year that was going to be good for
them personally and good for their
company I mean if you find someone who
has that right sort of champion material
I don't know if you guys cover the
Miller Heiman kind of model there's
always some I mean they're not a
champion if they don't have that element
early on and only a founder can I think
and really find that in the early days
so both of these guys signed up with us
when we didn't have a product so we gave
them the opportunity to help shape our
our product and provide requirements we
gave them things we didn't even think of
when we showed up for the meeting like
you know hey banner advertising yeah I'm
interested in that but do you be able to
do online research in a way that no one
at P&G is doing right now that's
interesting can you give me that and you
know we shave something that was very
going to be useful for them and then
they just felt connected to our company
forever I mean both of them are now
really good personal friends of mine and
I think you need that yeah and I
wouldn't underestimate it and that's why
I mean I'll come back to this later on
just don't hire a VP of Sales for a long
time you know until you know what you're
selling and why and I'm sure we'll all
sort of echo at different things around
timing flavor of sale what you're trying
to do with the structure is who your
champion is why they're your champion
it's just you got to do it but anyway
that's how it happened for us okay so
you know why put that off when we can
just sort of jump right into it now so
the next question I would have is as far
as looking for that first person so
you're trying to build your sales your
early sales and maybe a marketing person
you're looking for it maybe a sales
person the question is how do you find
the right person and maybe you could
also speak to when do you know it's time
to hire that person can we start with
working yeah back to Brad a little
unrest if you're gonna be really
effective is the head of your company
you need to just be a student of your
market the nature of demand why people
buy what people really buy not why you
want them to buy or think they should
buy and you know you got to know that
and the only way you're gonna really
know that is because you know you're
doing a lot of the initial marketing and
you're doing a lot of
selling you're really listening you're
there and you might not know the answer
to that question for some time and
you're feeling your way that's pretty
common in an early stage company and I
just I don't think you can bring on that
head of marketing of that head of sales
until you really know because you're
gonna bring on the wrong person it's
it's really common par for the course
that you're going to cycle through heads
of these different functions and the
longer you wait until you're just
confident that you get it there's a
reproducible sale here and this is why
people buy and this is the skill that I
need I mean just to sort of pick an
example the question we asked ourselves
in our software company now is do we
need someone who is a Content expert
that you know we sell analytic software
to call centers and you know field
service organizations so they just need
to understand that world or do they need
to understand technology or do they need
to understand how to build a lead
generation and direct you know you know
telesales organ it we just needed to
know what that profile was and it took
us quite a while to know that and the
same was true of marketing when we were
building the marketing engine and
BabyCenter which was about you know
addressing pregnant women basically the
you know we weren't sure how to do that
online no one really knew and in 1996
and 1997 and so we weren't sure do we
need a P&G or J and J or Unilever person
to do that or do we need like an Amex
direct response person to do that and
they mean they're incredibly skilled
people with lots of different
environments out there and we just you
got to wait until you know and well
that's the advice I'd I'd give on that
so as I said I did a lot of the initial
Sonya were basically two of us who were
their initial five people in the company
that kind of had very different skill
sets and I came out of the industry that
we were targeting one other Delmon came
out of market research because we're
somewhat a market research company but I
really weren't enterprise software
company that plays in market research
and we had you know I had technology
folks so we basically have five people
very different skill sets in the header
for what market research and I work did
all of the selling exclusively for the
first seven years of the company I would
say and we basically you know and again
it was I completely agree with market
was you know a we knew that you know we
kind of really got a hint and I handle
on what the customers wanted we built up
a lot of credibility ministry you know
clients and non clients like ball you
know kind of knew who we were and we
kept those relationships going
I think that was you know a huge benefit
and you know we were able to achieve a
seventy-five percent market share in the
industry just that way and I think that
we felt we needed to hire ahead of sales
when we were going to when we needed to
make a transformational change we
basically were trying to expand into
other industries and yeah one uh one
option we've been to go out and hire
somebody from each industry and have
them be the industry expert on sell or
to try and leverage you know what we had
in the hospitality across these other
industries and I think that we felt that
in the hospital industry the people the
buyers of this are very much the
operations people so having had that
experience was a huge benefit because
they're relating to you know you having
that experience and kind of being out
there in the field like they were but in
other industries that was bought more as
a traditional market research product
and so we felt that somebody who could
kind of leverage that knowledge of the
market research enterprise feedback
management industry would be very
helpful and in terms of penetrating some
of these other industries and so we just
last year hired a top sales executive
and we looked for a couple of things one
of them was um we feel cultural fit is
really important because at the end of
the day I think that's gonna be the
biggest thing for whether or not this
person is gonna be able to make it you
know successful he's successfully in our
company and one of the things in terms
of our culture are selling culture you
know was very much it was a very much a
soft sell long term strategy was not you
know kind of hard sell like you don't
want to buy spend a million dollars with
somebody who's because he used car
salesperson and you can't trust so it
was pretty much developing that trust
over time and so we wanted somebody who
he felt had that kind of a personality
and I think somebody who had we did feel
it was important to have a knowledge of
our industry and I think thirdly we were
really looking for somebody who we
thought could build a sales team
somebody who you know was good at
building sales teams knew how to
compensate people knew how to create
loyalty and that's what we really looked
for
when and who for us with with Nixon it
was about a year and we like you guys
the founders did the selling to the reps
the reps were doing that but we didn't
know how to manage a rep force I also
you have 24 reps in the states you have
eight distributors around the world and
we're focused on marketing a product and
again sales hits you in the face so we
knew that we needed somebody who have
that direct experience in our industry
that had had relationships with these
buyers you know for 10 or 15 years and
we got our elephant gun out and tried to
get the biggest guy we could get with
the biggest rolodex with the best
relationships and he got the biggest
part of our option for and that was in
June of 99 and he's been with us ever
since and he's a huge part of why we
still exist he knew what we didn't know
you know that people we didn't know so
he he really kind of took what we we put
together and sort of professionalized it
you know who we'll be looking for while
this guy had some relationships yes but
I I greeted by planning horizon and
culture and we were we were really
thinking that we were gonna create a
product that was just so sexy that
everybody would run out and get one and
that way you know another way of saying
we we we wanted a pull strategy you know
let's make this stuff really nice we
don't not gonna sell it bits with a gift
with purchase or you know it's cheaper
than everybody else it's got to be
pulled all the way through so the
planning horizon the ability to see that
strategy was important to us in a sales
guy to planning just because you know
here's it years a guy that had way more
experience than the company had and snap
your fingers if you is planning horizon
was 18 months or maybe two years he
would he would place our product in
retailers that just you know we wouldn't
be ready for we get placed and then
everybody scratch your head who's this
brand I never heard anything about it
and it may or may not work so it was
important to us that this guy understood
the pull strategy understood
okay we're gonna go from step one step
two to step three don't just go to step
three to make your bonus and then and
then leave in eighteen months so the
planning horizon was was really
important for us as well as
aggressiveness I mean sales guys they I
don't sales people I don't know where it
comes from but everybody in sales but
most aggressive people in our
organization so that that ability to
have a sales person with a pull strategy
was sort of who we were looking for
another company involved with is a
start-up vacuum cleaner company of all
things there's some new technology to it
it's pretty exciting it's it's it's it
just launched last fall these guys are
technology guys and and I said hey they
called me up and said how do you make a
product in China like making a product
in China is so easy because you're
spending the money anybody's gonna take
your phone call but how are you gonna
place this thing in Sears and the guy
really scratched his head for a while
that's it I'm gonna sell it online and
that's that's it that doesn't really
work in vacuum cleaners so he went out
and you know straight straight out of
the gate you know their their third
employee I think was you know VP of
Sales for for Dyson that he recruited
onto his startup team and again without
him I don't think they would have gotten
any product placed uh so we have a lot
of salespeople um and so I'd have to a
couple things that were said culture is
by far for us the most important when
hiring a head of sales or head of
marketing and secondly I would highly
advocate putting it off as long as
possible we've been through three VPS of
sales we've now got a stud who's been
with us for a while hopefully will be
with us forever
but a few things so Andy said aggressive
and we've got these you know a lot of
them inside of our company and the truth
is managing salespeople is brutal
it's tough they all think they run the
company they're in your office every day
they want more money they want less work
they complain about why they can't sell
they complain about customer service and
we were eager to offload that and we
thought a VP of Sales is a great
solution
so our problem number one was we had
direct relationships with all of these
people and they they were literally our
friends could we bootstrapped the
company and you know the first our first
via PC VPS sales came in with 25
salespeople VP of Sales comes in and
we're relatively young and tells us what
we don't know how our culture is bad how
our systems are bad everything's changed
and we say well he's gray hair VP of
Sales ok we start changing things turned
out to be a disaster he didn't
understand our industry we took him from
outside the industry and it was a
mistake and the salespeople when you
bring a new VP of Sales into a sales
organization they aren't going to revolt
it's it's like a truism I have to
imagine because they're threatened and
he that person wants to change things so
we terminated the first guy and now we
set the precedent that the inmates are
running the asylum because they told us
fired scam fine so we brought in the
second VP of Sales and similar things
happen cultural differences the third
person that we hired and ended up
literally being a friend who we've been
working with for years and was the guy
that we'd go out and drink beers with
who ran a big sales organization and say
why can't we get sales right and it
turned out well we're hiring salespeople
which sales people aren't infamously bad
managers generally and we're not getting
the right person who understands our
culture appreciates our culture respects
our people and people respect him so the
last one who's founding with us for
three years system very successful but
culture really important put it off as
long as possible and we now have a
policy internally that we won't hire a
VP or or above level from a search our
first two salespeople were from an
outside search cost us money you end up
definitionally getting someone who's
either seeking or willing to be lured
away which means when they're in your
organization the same things gonna
happen so now we basically only hire
referrals for VP and above or internally
promote as you know little specific bit
of feedback
so I have other questions to ask the
panel but I'm not going to ask them so
I'm going to apologize to Michelle and
to Drew who worked with me to come up
with some of these advanced questions
I'm sure there are good ones out here in
the audience as well the other thing
I'll say to the panel is we shared some
of our preliminary questions with them
we said you know give this some thought
so some of you may be disappointed in
thinking oh I had a killer answer to
that question that you were gonna ask me
but let's take a lesson from the
political candidates who are out in the
hustings now it doesn't really matter
what question these guys ask if you have
a really good answer you'll figure out
how to get an innocent right so you know
feel free to take that bit of life so
with that what I'd like to do is spend
the remainder of the time fielding your
questions my job as the moderator is to
simply try to get around to as many of
you as possible what I would ask you to
do is if you put your hand up think
first of all is this question going to
be interesting to somebody other than me
in this room if you think there's one
other person then that's sort of a good
indicator that it's a sufficiently
general question when you ask the
question you can pose it either to the
panel or to a specific individual in the
panel and we'll see how you know they
want to handle it from there all right
so with that please raise your hand if
you have a question that you'd like to
ask David
sometime in season there's a big
difference between our good sales people
don't always make good sales manager
yeah how do you pick the difference when
picking a manager or a rep or if you
want to promote your reps into
management yeah it's a great question
that we struggle with a lot is we have a
lot of people and we are now at an
evolution in our company what we're
dealing with you have to promote people
or they're gonna get frustrating to
leave so we the way that we structure
our sales organization I manage sales we
have a VP two directors several managers
and then pods of eight person sales
teams each with a team lead who's a
selling person we have consistently made
this error and this I don't know what
the solution in this one's but we
promoted early on our best sales people
into the team lead position the best
sales person correct me if I'm wrong but
self-centered very aggressive very money
driven very competitive will stab
somebody the back to get a sale
it's what successful by the way give not
opinionated it's what makes them great
now we promote that person to a team
lead position yeah almost every time as
a problem so the things that for us has
made great managers teamwork cohesion
looking out for other people's best
interests before that their own is it
very challenging thing in sales so now
we sort of do a 360 review we talked to
the people on their team we talked to
the VP of Sales we have a serious sit
down with them and figure out is it is
upward mobility the right thing for them
the other challenge is very frequently
when we promote them into positions of
management they make less money so now
you get in this horrible situation which
is a real cash point - because
inherently it's human nature you want to
move up you want to be promoted but you
want these guys want more money so it's
a real challenge that we we haven't
solved and we've lost some top
salespeople because I think they burn
out after six years and we say this
person is a great salesperson not a
great manager I think the VP level were
pretty clear and manager level we've
gone out
organization people have run large large
you know sales groups but it is a I mean
it's an ongoing struggle that we deal
with you know everyday in sales other
other groups you know no problem
anybody else I may just jump in if you
have a perspective I guess sure I agree
I think about the issue of the
personality fit in some ways I think
that the salesperson naturally is always
gonna want what's best for them which
hopefully if your incentives are correct
is best for the company but the sales
manager has to be somebody that's
willing to kind of you know not
necessarily do what's best for them but
do what's best for the team or the
company and I think that you'll see a
very different personality out of that
it doesn't mean that the salesperson the
sales manager couldn't necessarily have
been a good like isn't a good
salesperson in some ways but they're
just it's a different slightly different
person personality I mean our head of
sales he does do sales and he's pretty
effective at it but he's not the best
sales person on the team sure other
questions in the back Glengarry Glen
Ross excuses
so yes I'd say ones money okay you if
they're motivated by money you align
their compensation I'll give you another
early mistake that we made is we're a
bunch of MBA students and we're private
equity you guys would love spreadsheets
we built all these models and ROI models
and how to best compensate people and of
course that ends up being a hundred
percent variable but bootstrapped
you know we're pretty lean on money so
you know you kind of eat what you kill
now you we can't get our sales people to
show up to work anymore once they've hit
their quota and you know they big they
kind of like gunslingers so we changed
that model and then honestly for us its
culture is just a huge deal we really do
love them up a ton we celebrate all
their accomplishments that the top guys
don't complain it's the guys that don't
sell that are full of excuses generally
and frankly part of the sales
organization is we turn people over you
know pretty frequently but in terms of
you know keeping people happy and in
overcoming their objections you know
it's a big part of it we the founders
spend a lot of time a disproportionate
amount of time with the sales
organization to be honest and you know
you got to figure out what each person
is motivated by and it is money for a
lot of great salespeople but for some
people it's recognition public
recognition so we do lots of
competitions and reward lots of
different little things very publicly
you know for some people it is actually
watching people on their team succeed so
the team model for us has been great
because there are you get pretty good
cohesion and then the teams like to
compete against each other in your line
incentives there and in lots of Red Bull
keeps them all it just keeps a sales
organization just sort of spinning I
have a have a slightly different point
of view I love managing salespeople and
hate managing engineers gonna be and the
reason is I mean love them they're gray
we have mostly engineers at our company
and the reason is because it's a you
know where we have these big sales
campaigns they take six to 12 months so
there's lots of activity to manage
and the right salespeople for us a very
process driven and process oriented so
there's lots of things to study and if
someone's not following the process
they're not pursuing the campaign in the
right way you know you you know it's
going to work or not work long before
you get to results and at the end of the
day it's the results that matter they'll
leave or you'll you'll terminate them
and try to and put that kind of process
on a product development and engineering
organization it just doesn't work you
know it's a it's much harder so you just
you know you hope you have motivated
people and great engineering leadership
so you know for us the to avoid the
Glengarry Glen Ross thing one you gotta
have the right set of incentives you
know and you have lots of opportunities
to change your incentives and your comp
plan and your structure to make people
sure people are going the right way and
then you know let people notice a lot
more than just the result that you know
matters for their advancement and for
their success you know how we do 360 and
peer review we do customer feedback for
every rep we do you know activity and
pipeline you know reporting every single
week there all sorts of things you can
do to manage it if someone's a baby and
you know they're not really sort of
living up to the job they'll get
rejected by our organization and then
you know the big dilemma really is
someone who's an incredible rain maker
and a baby that's the hard part that
point excuse me very early on our bonus
structure was completely up to my
discretion said look we have a history I
don't know if you're gonna sell 50%
hundred percent hundred fifty percent do
you know I don't know nobody knows so
yeah you're gonna be motivated by your
bonus and this is this is what a range
might be and then how much you get is
you just gotta trust me
that's what I told my sales guy trust me
that if you you good a job you play fair
and everything else then then I'll take
care of you and and and I had to because
the guys hit their targets the other one
no sales guys they're gonna run point
while the operations guys in ship and
the product guys are late and the
marketing guys that adds way off and and
it's a you know it's a huge flash late
into the depths of the organization is
like great you know okay knowing now
here now I know what to work out you
know just I kind of to quiet down your
sales team those are the areas I need to
fix or I should concentrate
because those guys are they know what's
shipping what don't it's not shipping
and why that's the great thing about
selling yourself because you just be
playing the finger yourself basically if
things go wrong or you have nobody to
complain to right but I think that one
of the things I would add to this is
that um really focused on getting the
product right because it's great to sell
a good product I mean you walk into
clients and they love your product try
it I mean it was it was never you didn't
have to ever go in and it was so it was
it's always it was easy to sell it
wasn't cuz the cell cycles were long and
they were big amounts of money but you
know we had people saying I mean we had
people who didn't buy from us that said
we love your product right um there were
other reasons it's cost or whatever but
I mean it was a very easy thing to sell
and so that kind of makes it nice to be
a sales person you have a lot less to
objective
we in the really early days well with it
with a salesperson it's hard to deviate
from the cash comp that's in your
industry and in my experience you know
you might play with equity go up a lot
down a lot it won't matter the cash
comps the cash company industry that's
my experience in sales is very different
in a you know engineering possibly
marketing and some other functions
Kirstin or what other people think so
we've we try to be competitive on equity
but generally we match you know what
what happens in our industry and then
you know all the companies I've been a
part of you know we try to maximize the
variable piece but there's usually an
industry standard for what the base is
and then it's really about taking that
variable piece and designing it in such
a way that you're driving the right
behavior and people can do really well
and you want people to do really well
it's kind of stock answer that's what we
yeah I mean all right in our case um
there is a new distressed and 'red I
mean it's probably the same standards
for for mark about how much of the sale
basically the salesperson should get and
we don't put any caps obviously there's
a big equity component as well for the
senior I think that the actual sales
people are very focused on that how much
am I gonna make this year so making sure
that you know that there's a big upside
for them cuz that's the new behavior
that she wants some ways this is
important it's a really quick just to
add something so if it's a short sales
cycle you can juice the variable
component cuz they're gonna get paid
pretty quick it's a long sales cycle
they're not gonna hang out that long for
that they'll take the guaranteed thing
the other thing is an early stage
organization depending what level that
person is in the other organization you
do have significant opportunity to shape
your organization's an early employee
and significant opportunity for career
advancement then maybe if you're leaving
IBM and your eight levels down an
organization you know it's 30 years
until you get the director level you
know that may really be meaningful to
that individual to say if you're
successful here at entering in a manager
level you could be director in a year
VP and three years
for some people that is you know really
resonates in our heads animation so I
see you have sales experience alright I
think here's what I'd say you're selling
yourself to your first employees you're
selling yourself to your clients you're
selling yourself to your investors
you're selling yourself to your board
every day you sell yourself to your
employees sales is the most important
thing that you as a founder do even
though it's probably not defined as
sales for me I had none I did get it you
know on the job we made a lot of
mistakes for us that was okay though we
entered a market where it kind of bailed
us out a little bit but I would feel
very strongly it's a lot of work it's a
tough job where you get rejected a lot
but you know so is running a company so
I haven't strongly advocated for that
any opposing or alternative views of it
it's one those disciplines either good
at it or not in it you know it's it's
like you know some people are just great
musicians some people aren't great
musicians I think there's a lot in terms
of the skills that you can acquire but I
think there are some people who can sort
of show up as a founder start selling
and be really effective you don't need
to have been to the Xerox program and I
think there are other people who might
not naturally good at it and some
fundamental training would be a really
useful thing yeah but I completely agree
with the statement that the you know
that this or the you know the arrows in
your quiver and in sales are just you'd
be essential when you're a company
founder you just need to use them all
the time okay
culture company through the national my
hurry
and those people are not logistical
located different states I don't know
who wants to sell beans our sale we put
a lot of money into our sales meetings
we get an entire entire team together
for three four or five days we make sure
that there's product there's all the
normal things of a sales meeting but
then again we try to put it in a really
fun place and that's in a you know top
of the mountain in Switzerland we've
been there Costa Rica I mean everything
involved with our industry you know in
the action sports yeah so the cultural
piece was that was art one time to have
a real face-to-face with all all the
sales team
yes sermons absolutely overall
geographically for small company made
start Christmas to replica of overseas
or we're only domestic so we we just
internationalized our products and built
European operations this last year and
we waited a long time we actually had
orders from Japan that we turned down in
the early years because we were certain
we would screw it up badly and that's
not what we mistake we could afford to
make so we waited until we had we really
understood that particular region we
understood the sales model and we knew
that our product was of equality and
could be internationalized before we did
it and in our industry there's kind of a
set of rules that makes that kind of
easy to make the decision that way but
we waited till we were ready we waited a
long time as well I think part of it is
you know just knowing that market being
able to sell into it especially when
you're a business to business customers
it's very challenging in that way and I
think we we had an initial angel
investor but we basically you know were
funded completely out of cash flow and
we're profitable after three years and
so to some degree it was a resource
issue I mean we yeah we kind of wanted
to get the market here in North America
before we I'm one international and so
we did that about two years ago and now
we're operating on all continents so we
went right away and it was a source of
financing we went to distributors
outside of out of the states who would
then we could use their orders to back
up our own with the factory and and that
helped us as a financing tool as much as
anything but that to talk to the right
distributor and just make sure they
understand the brand and our our
sequence of what we wanted to do in
terms of launching the brand that was
part of the hardest part
well back Elsie's you know the
distributor from Japan would place a big
order so we take we have them write a
letter of credit and then we take that
to our bank and just transfer that to
our car vendor and that really kind of
saved us actually we got us off the
ground or if they don't wanna do an LC
it's like I'm fine give me a 50% deposit
cash 90 days before I deliver or not
they're going to leverage an existing
distribution system or whether you're
trying to build your own the mark is
saying that we couldn't take our own and
build it out that fast we had to
actually have the discipline to say no
is actually kind of interesting and
refreshing to hear about companies that
turn down orders but you know the
discipline to say you know it gets us in
trouble if we try to go too far too fast
the only thing worse than an angry
disappointed customers an angry
disappointed distributor you know we
knew even if we chose to go with that
model in Europe or in Asia they'd be
incredibly knowledgeable in their anger
so yeah we weren't ready and effective
at spreading the word yes
we raised smaller and venture capital in
2001 we got profitable on that so we we
the big decision in our business which
is really software specific thing is
switching from a traditional licensing
model where they pay up front for the
software and then implement overtime to
this sort of more you know nouveau
software as a service subscription model
where you know it's very expensive for a
number of years but then you have great
recurring revenue and we're still sort
of wrestling with we do both when we
make the switch so because we get paid
upfront for our software we've kind of
found into the growth of our company
we're now we've got ten times the cash
and receivables as the total amount that
we capitalize the company with in 2001
and it's all our customers and that's
been really really painful and hard but
you know it sounds like we're in the
same situation we had an initial round
of emotional angel investor and we
bought him out and have been profitable
as a since that yeah since 2003
I'm just funded out of cash flow and we
are a software for certain a
subscription service basically so we
have some initial you know
implementation fees but really we have
kind of huge revenue streams that
hopefully if you don't lose customers go
on quite a long time and we haven't lost
a customer yet so you talked about
having distribution people were you able
to get distribution and your reputation
prior to getting the first big sales or
in it require that you did the first big
sales yourself and then the
distributor's became interested in our
and the businesses I've been in selling
direct initially was essential and I
know that's not the case and lots of
businesses but in the ones we're in in
it
um it it was also a sort of a conviction
that we had early on we wanted to make
sure that we were more knowledgeable
about the problem because we were
building software or you know consumer
Internet experience around it it was
there was no sort of existing channel
and if we weren't in direct contact with
the customer and we weren't gathering
the requirements and figuring out what
was bad and why it was bad and all those
things then you know we were missing
kind of key requirements that had
defeated the product development
organization and we wouldn't have this
sort of sales advantage that we wanted
to have so we waited a number of years
before we formed distribution
relationships so we've only recently
done it it's been really good but we
chose to wait good guy with experience
in themselves because you cannot form
you cannot for this guy Baker probably
they are working with other company and
they have a good Commission so they said
why I don't know your product the people
don't know your product so maybe it's
hard to do the product so he's hard to
get this guy because he said well I have
the Commission already getting good
money I'm going to take a huge risk with
you you are a small company you are
sorry so in one point I know that some
community it's easier to gather your own
cells people like a star the star with
them maybe is people that you trust and
you want to teach them and maybe grow
with them or try to find out a guy with
the experience with with more expertise
in the market and well maybe pay more
maybe take the racecar maybe get a take
the best this guy so I know what's
better or what's better funny why we
think about these more situations
of well maybe I kind of start with these
people I trust they don't know anything
but I can teacher maybe I have to find
this guy who has experience in the
market and I'll go for the side I know
in your experience so I mean this is
gonna answer your question but I'll tell
you really quickly this will be my
client political answer in Malaysia it's
your first couple salespeople I'd pay up
is once you get everything systematized
and Mark talked about this little bit
you get the sales process dialed in you
can plug bees in you can't plug bees in
and it's sort of Denova when you're
trying to figure out your sales process
and culture and your early sales people
are going to have such a big impact on
what you are five years down the road
because they're gonna complain about all
the other processes including their
sales processes I would have a bias if
you're gonna stretch on peyer's get some
really good sales people are long they
will who are culturally good fit and
give you positive feedback they'll help
you refine all those systems processes
and help create a stronger company going
forward I'd say that is it's not just
sales that you're building
yeah you're building the organization so
I would wouldn't have a people across
the board now the chance of actually
finding those in each functional part of
the company is is pretty slim you know
you're not gonna find the great
operations guy the great finance guy the
great sales guy great mark I mean not
gonna find them all if you do then
that's a great problem to have now which
one should I pick and of my resources
you know which one am I getting kind of
you I set the bar pretty high on it
across the board and then then trying to
find the best I could find in each group
it just turned out that you'd find some
green green people that weren't you
didn't have to pay up for in some areas
of the business and sound Superstars and
others more opportunistic I guess if I
were to answer this I've been teaching
this sales man has been elected with
Mark Lester here at the GSB for about
five years we brought in dozens of sales
professionals who've been on panels and
so on and I believe that if you asked
that question to them they would almost
unanimously respond that what you need
to do is you need to find experience you
don't hire somebody into a new
organization and and somehow endow them
with what they need to manage the
growing sales organization that you're
trying to build now that means you get
really creative at convincing them to
come and join you find ways of doing it
but look for the experience out there so
you can bring the person in that you
need okay to sell and I think that's
cute my question for you is how
important is a good brand
I think it's astounding that you were
able to use your connections to get the
mix of watches into these places but to
have the self through with an unknown
brand how important is grant and Kevin
have you've done direct-to-consumer
sales online to establish that brand
well I guess from my perspective I think
like when you're in a business to
business industry versus a business
consumer I think maybe there's a
different answer here because I think
that we sold as I said we we were able
to sell based on our personal networks
our personal reputations again in places
where as you know if we did I think the
brand might have been more important if
we didn't have that right and if we were
kind of really going after a mass-market
you know I think that you know because
we had the product because we had you
know the networks we were able to do
that but I think it was kind of
interesting because I found even five
years into it when we had over 50% of
the market there were RFPs that went out
with it we were not invited on and it
was shocking to me when this would
happen you know because you would think
you know we have 50% market we would it
we've invited to answer an RFP and
that's where I think branding in some
ways you know we fell down on branding
because I think we were so busy on
selling and I mean marketing kind of
came secondary in some ways right and we
were focused on selling and engineering
and delivering and we kind of said you
know we'll deal with that thing later so
we're dealing with it now but because
now we're trying to enter new industries
and there we feel if people understand
our brand understand what we've done
salary that that'll that'll help
tremendously for us it was critical I
mean we needed what there had to be a
story of why why our watch wasn't just a
hunk of metal next to another hunk of
metal next to another hunk of metal on a
shelf somewhere and the the the
retailers are you know they're
risk-averse like anybody else and they
they want to make sure that that will
sell through so if you don't have the
story to sell them on how are you gonna
create the brand the awareness outside
of you know outside of there or outside
of their door they won't they don't
bring it in so we we we were focused
completely on what our story is and it
will that be being able to be told at on
the shelf to the to the consumer and we
went we went online very very quietly to
avoid channel conflict and we still have
a strategy of pushing sales to our
retailers supporting our retail a retail
base but if the if if somebody's out
there and wants to buy from us take they
can you know we haven't done a consumer
in a business to business company I'd
say brand always matters but they mean
different things you know so brand on
the enterprise side is about the
one-on-one people interactions with the
people in your company and word-of-mouth
reputation so we have very consultative
sales people they're not slick you know
that that's the brand you know for the
company whereas it you know baby center
which was consumer oriented it was you
know we never interacted with the
customer that was all about the their
experience with the website and that it
be trusted and quality and things that
you know moms cared about intensely but
you know when I look at the company let
me brand mattered an enormous way just
differently okay so what about when it
comes to developing your products if you
go to market and you don't know send
clients or the customer then you're
gonna bomb out because we don't miss the
market you don't understand
so how do you find out what their pain
is before this product I can take a
crack that is you talk to a lot of
people and you talk to people outside of
your circle for us we didn't know what
our products were gonna be our initial
launch with freedom Financial Network
was to do consumer financial advisory
services to help people with serious
money problems we had no idea when our
product was gonna be and we thought
people with money problems must read the
National Enquirer shows what we knew
that is like the worst place in the
world to get leads for what we do
we put an ad we didn't know what our
product was and my Kofun right answered
our cell phones at all hours of the
night he said what do you need help with
what resonates with you what's your
primary problems and we personally were
just for free solving people's problems
and put him in touch with people we
start aggregating hundreds of data
points and pretty quickly we got to a
little loop where it was like you know
the 8020 rule and we felt like oh this
is interesting we keep seeing the same
problems over and over and and people
are referring their buddy to say hey you
solved my problem in a neat way and then
we went out and marketed those we didn't
have a brand so we didn't be focused on
features in our world of got to everyone
was focused on their monthly payment
which for us was not intuitive we
thought we were in the market save more
money and then we started marketing
these little features for us cut monthly
payments with these innovative financial
services products and the phone just
starts ringing off the hook and then we
say oh we got it
and then we tailor our product to that
pretty quickly
no no we don't say that but we do debt
resolution tax resolution student loan
consolidation mortgages conforming
mortgages and then and then consumer
financial advisory services free through
bills.com consumer price standpoint
listening to the retailer it could be
dangerous
because its rear view mirror I just got
myself to report and the green one sold
and the big one sold so what are they
gonna tell you give me a big green one
who needs a big green one so so we we
tried it we you know I was sell through
reports and listen to our retailers but
we try to work with the guys that that
feel comfortable enough with us saying
yes this is gonna work so it's more up
front you know the focus group type
stuff we did we just negotiated into our
original contract that we could we'd get
two days a month on-site in his call
centers for a product development
organization and product managers and we
got a year of in-depth requirements
gathering and that was part of the deal
in the original contract so we built our
product around you know real customer
requirements and I would I would agree
with that too I think I'm you know fine
I find someone that knows that market
well that has experienced those pain
points I mean that was actually me when
I first started with the company and
then basically talked to a lot of other
people so we called I mean people we
knew I knew we called cold called into
these organizations for the people who
bought this and said we're starting this
business and we want to understand what
it is you would look from this and
amazing amount of people you know we
talked to us and we already had some
ideas of things that we thought would
work or what more can we test at those
those people and it was actually kind of
a good presale networking thing because
then when we had something we came back
and called those same people you know
I'd make one more comment there to is on
the recruiting front in recruiting
salespeople it's a great great way to
get intelligence about what's working
not salespeople good salespeople love to
talk and when you are recruiting them
and you I mean in business well you guys
should go to the library and get like a
career builder or hot Jobs account and
just start calling people that are doing
sales that are looking for jobs and say
what worked what didn't what message is
sold effectively and I'll bet you you'll
learn a ton about what does and what
doesn't work
how do you figure out whether it is
still the pipeline and tell them or
breath but really focus down do try to
get the clothes you know we we developed
a pipeline methodology not immediately
but pretty soon you know with a really
ruthless qualification process so you
know upper out upper out you're either
migrating the opportunity to make a sale
was either you know advancing or we're
not gonna spend time on it and we just
try to stick to that philosophy so you
know if we're chasing a two million
dollar a six million dollar sales
opportunity which is what we do you know
there's there sure signs that it's not
advancing that your champion is weak or
there is objection somewhere in the
organization and you know I don't think
I have much but a general answer to say
just have to have that discipline you
know to look the salesperson in the eye
and say you've got happy years we're not
gonna spend time there that's enough
you know let's move on to the next one
and we just did our best to to do that I
think our our experience might have been
a slightly different one because we we
basically we had a target list and it
was drawn at a very high level because
there were very few of us there were two
of us right and we were also designing
product and you know so basically we you
know it was drawn it basically the top
20 companies in the industry so and yeah
these are huge global organizations
right with 6,000 properties and so on so
we targeted that list we you know
aggressively tried to get contacts at
the senior level into that group and we
basically developed relationships
throughout as many relationships to put
in those organizations and we kept those
up I mean we I'm still very good
relationships with people who are not
clients we invited we basically started
up a conference at best practices
conference for the industry and we have
like clients and on client's alike
and it's kind of interesting because we
it was a big risk we felt because we had
a couple major competitors in the
industry and we were very concerned at
the outgo that you know we thought we
had kind of a competitive advantage with
them both our product in general and we
have a benchmarking product that's
across industry no it's kind of one of
our we had like a that was our special
selling thing right so we said you can
only get this through us right and we
didn't want really the other
you know pliers to find out about it so
we were in kind of stealth mode for so
long you our website had one page it was
ridiculous if you tried to research that
she got this one page right so we
thought nobody's gonna actually talk to
us when they see one page up there right
but we have we invited to this
conference and you know because we knew
enough people you know we got people to
come and know now it's we've had the
third one just last year and we had you
know every major hotel company client or
not has come to this and they actually
talk I mean it's weird you get a bunch
of competitive and they tell each other
what they do in this area right but it's
hugely beneficial to us because a you
know now it's kind of a standardized
thing people only can you know we are
the only one that has this and we get a
lot of intelligence that we build into
our product out of it
so sometimes have to be willing to take
a little bit risk like that you know but
I think your your question kind of gets
at the heart of what a good salesperson
does naturally they prioritize
ruthlessly and they know where to you
know they're scarce commodity is time
and you know they can waste a lot of
time if they're going in the wrong
direction and a truly effective sales VP
or sales director can monitor their
people and make sure that they're using
their time judiciously and instead of
just going scattershot it's hard to give
you a precise answer yeah some point you
do have to say I'm not gonna I'm gonna
give this one up for now right when we
did that we walked away we've walked
away from sales where we said okay you
know we know we're gonna have to give
this one up for now but we still kept
that relationship going because some day
and I mean this worked out great I mean
we had one you know one of the major
hotel companies we invited to our first
conference and we made a connection
there and they came back the next year
and all along we heard the board is you
know we can't fund this project it's too
much money they had an internal
homegrown thing and you know three years
later there was a change in the
executive leadership there and now there
are clients so but yeah we were willing
to walk away at that budget do you guys
use viral marketing buzz marketing PR
and like how did you time it how do you
say okay it's worth it for us to make
this investment that yeah I mean my
partner figured that part out but what I
mean
instead of making and making you know go
to a trade show and you see your t-shirt
everywhere on on everybody was his goal
and we you know we make 20 t-shirts and
find the 20 right people and those guys
were everywhere so you know 20 t-shirts
goes a long way because near a trade
show with you know thousands of
exhibitors who I keep on seeing these
things and it's also you know getting
you know really really just just first
level and finding people to proselytize
for you and who are the who the athletes
that we used where they might show up
doing little little things for for
influential people and then that it goes
influential people do the marketing for
you I don't know that's not very
practical but 20 t-shirts sometimes is
way more effective than 2,000 I guess my
point is and if you find the right
people with those it goes a long way
this is probably your market with
something complex like enterprise
software
influence you to change the product I'm
imagining you there temptation to change
it enough to do whatever you need to to
close the sale your have an issue where
you change it so much or you're worried
about changing so much you couldn't sell
if anybody else yeah I mean that's a
primary concern in enterprise software
if you're so customer driven for the
first few or the really big ones you
become a job shop and ruin your company
so we you know had enough experience
under our belts to know that that was
just a fatal mistake and you know huh I
mean it's one thing to say that
thematically it's another thing to just
you know scare you know t-mobile GE or
MX in the face and say no I'm not going
to build that and if that means we lose
the deal then so be it but that's what
we did and but you know we did need to
have enough enough people in our network
and enough other sort of prospects and
folks that would if someone said hey
here's something I want to do actually
get our biggest customers Dell and
they're incredibly aggressive and
effective and demanding customer I mean
we would consume our whole product
development organization if we just did
what they want but fortunately we're now
at a scale with you know 50 or 60
customers that they say hey this is
great everybody's gonna want it we're
like okay I'll get back to you tomorrow
you know and we we make a bunch of phone
calls and listen we can answer the
question but no it's a good question
because that's a that's a company record
if you're not careful
but the first one or my last minute
really interesting question so first of
all I took on the additional role of
meeting plan act a salesperson and
basically we decided that I mean this is
a bunch of hospitality people right I
mean we actually haven't had our first
cross industry conference right but the
next one will be cross industry because
you know now we have a fidelity and Nike
and Apple and all these big players that
you know we want to share knowledge
across these industries right but you
know with at that point time we were
exclusively in hospitality and um you
know you get a bunch of hospitality
people they've been everywhere right you
know to get them to come like there has
to be a draw right so we basically have
you been in the industry I've made up a
list of 10 places that I thought we
could get these people to come to
because a you know it's kind of an
interesting place they wanted to visit
and be they were kind of we could hold
them captive for a couple days because
that's another thing about hospitality
if you go to New York City they're all
gonna stand there on hotel and you lose
some of that like a lot of this whole
conferences networking it's you know we
have it's it's not light on content but
it's equally heavy on networking I would
say and so basically you know we had at
that point we probably had I don't know
maybe five major clients but you know we
ended it only kept it small that was the
other thing we always it was invitation
only and we paid for everything with the
flights so it was basically it was our
big marketing investment for the year
really and you know we think it's it's
paid off incredibly I mean we've gotten
directly to sales you know major major
sales out of that and you know it is
kind of you know it is the place to go
now for this and it's kind of
interesting because there was we kind of
got the idea out of there was kind of an
informal thing that have been set up by
a lot of these um people in the industry
who do this and they had themselves set
up this quality council where they would
share these ideas right and so we were
like well this is a really interesting
concept and so we thought well let's try
you know doing one of ours where we talk
about best practices and our tool and we
go through our roadmap and you know get
input and so we kind of came up
but it isn't a need you have to make an
investment I mean it's hard to get
people there the first time once it kind
of is successful people talk about it
and now we don't have any trouble so 22
shirts do that
for us who they are is pretty relevant
readily available the latter was a much
bigger problem depending what industry
you guys are going into you know
self-serving for you all but Stanford
GSB actually knows a pretty long way in
consumer finance a subprime Consumer
Finances along not a lot of Stanford
Business School guys doing it
Chuck Holloway is on our board we
leveraged him quite a bit and he has
been really integral in us getting into
some big banks that we would never ever
touched and then pretty quickly you
execute really well on the first one
make absolutely certain you don't screw
it up and then word of mouth spreads
pretty quickly too and be willing to get
on a plane you know anytime anywhere
even if you BS it and say oh I'm gonna
be in Charlotte next week you know can I
stop by and you book a flight and go to
Charlotte I mean you know I think
networking is a really really big thing
and fortunately for us the GSB has been
pretty beneficial it's opened a lot of
doors and our board members Chuck's been
really valuable yeah you happened to be
in a lot of cities that's right
can you talk a little bit about how
within the organization you've divided
up sales business vel and marketing
strategy sort of the early stages leader
depending on whether it's against a to B
versus B to C so we have different
functional areas I'll just go really
quick we divide direct and indirect
channels as two totally separate groups
they both report up to me everything in
front of our business does and actually
that's important we've had problems
where we are overcompensating channel
partners and your sales people will find
out about it
and want to go and be a Channel Partner
pretty quick but then we have functional
areas with VPS of every group I'd say
the two that indirect channel and
business development is essentially one
in the same an organization and then
marketing the sales are two different
distinct groups but they talk eighteen
times a day and they actually have
compensation plans that are correlated
so the marketing guys get comped on
customer acquisition cost which depends
on the sales people closing same with
sales so they're very friendly they talk
a lot so we can we keep them separate
but we have shared compensation of a
portion of their conversation you know
for us I guess it was different across
the companies but in the current
software company we've got you know
sales which is all about direct sales
you know to enterprise customers in
various markets bizdev just like you is
establishing new indirect sales channels
and also bringing in other products that
we want to rebrand and resell and oh
yeah we miss Deb does that and then
there's two flavors of marketing there's
a kind of corporate marketing in Markham
and the new PR analysts website lead
generation events Field Marketing and
then product marketing which is about
gathering requirements developing MRDs
overseeing product development so we've
got all this and at BabyCenter it was
different still because it was a
consumer business so we had a lot of
brand marketing and you know bizdev was
about two alliances to get traffic and
things like that so michelle window our
lives our session in
that ends up 2:30 so will you please
thank you all for your participation